NARRATOR:
Beneath the clear blue waters
of the Mediterranean lie
treasures of ancient empires,
relics of their bloody wars,
and secrets of the seismic
forces that shaped them,
lost beneath the waves...
until now.
Imagine if we could
empty the oceans,
letting the water drain away
to reveal the secrets
of the seafloor.
Now, we can.
Using the latest underwater
scanning technology,
piercing the deep oceans,
and turning accurate data
into 3D images.
This time,
what apocalyptic disaster
triggered the collapse
of Europe's first civilization?
Can an extraordinary
2,500-year-old shipwreck
unlock the secrets
of Ancient Greece?
How did these deadly objects
turn Ancient Rome
into a superpower?
And why does the Sin City
of the Roman Empire
lie abandoned
beneath the waves?
(music)
Ancient people call it
the Middle Sea,
the center of the known world.
The Egyptians,
Greeks and Romans
build mighty civilizations
upon its shores.
Empires battle for supremacy
across its waters.
Cities grow rich and powerful
through trade.
The Mediterranean becomes
a superhighway,
connecting cultures that
will shape the modern world.
But only by draining the sea
can we reveal
its biggest and most
terrifying secret.
What happened on this
spectacular Greek island
to doom an entire civilization?
COSTAS SYNOLAKIS: They must have
thought this was it,
the end of the world.
NARRATOR: 3,600 years ago.
15 centuries before
the Roman Empire.
A mysterious people dominate
the Mediterranean.
We call them the Minoans.
Their home is on Crete.
Here they build magnificent
temples and palaces,
and decorate them
with stunning frescoes.
Celebrating their love
of life and of nature.
But there's a darker side, too.
The Minoan royal palace
at Knossos
is said to contain a labyrinth.
Home to the Minotaur.
A fearsome creature...
part man, part bull,
with a terrible appetite
for human flesh.
But apart from a grisly myth,
much about the Minoan world
still remains a mystery.
MICHAEL SCOTT: We can't
decipher their language.
We only have their
archaeological remains,
but what that tells us, I think,
is that they were
extremely imaginative,
they were extremely adventurous,
and that they developed
a sophisticated
hierarchical society
that was capable of producing
elements of art and architecture
which still astound us today.
NARRATOR: Historians do know
that the Minoans spread
across the Mediterranean,
trading olive oil and pottery
for gold and ivory,
growing ever richer
and more powerful.
And then,
in the 15th century BC,
their ancient civilization
begins to fade
from the pages of history.
For centuries,
no one knows why.
Until scientists start
to look closely
at the nearby island
of Santorini.
SYNOLAKIS: Santorini, it has
this very, very calm water.
It's almost like it plays
with you and deceives you.
Looking at this view,
you would never imagine
how dangerous it once was
and how dangerous it is.
NARRATOR: The island is famous
for its spectacular,
jagged cliffs,
which tower above
a beautiful natural harbor.
But what created them?
And can they help explain
the downfall of the Minoans?
Marine geologist Evi Nomikou
believes that crucial clues
may lie deep beneath
Santorini's tranquil waters.
EVI NOMIKOU:
As I was born in Santorini,
I wanted to study the area
to reveal their secret.
Being a marine geologist means
that you're having access
to the mystic world
of the seafloor,
so you can see features
that nobody else can see.
NARRATOR:
She harnesses the latest
multi-beam sonar technology
to scan the depths
of the huge bay.
By transforming her data
into powerful computer imagery,
it's possible to drain away the
waters of the Mediterranean...
(music)
...and reveal Santorini's
terrifying secret.
The sheer cliffs tower
1,000 feet above sea level
and drop a further 1,000 feet
to the seafloor.
Framing a vast basin
large enough to hold
10,000 Olympic stadiums.
The basin is a huge crater,
and Santorini itself is the
remnant of a gigantic volcano.
(music)
But that's not all.
On the rim of the crater,
more evidence of Santorini's
violent past.
(music)
(screams)
Undiscovered until 1967,
these shattered ruins
are all that remain
of a once-thriving city,
known today as Akrotiri.
It was destroyed when
the volcano erupted,
and buried under so much ash
that it remained hidden
for 3,500 years.
LEFTERIS ZORZOS: It's almost
like a window back in time,
where you can see how it was
when it was destroyed.
NARRATOR: And deep in the ruins
archaeologists discover
something remarkable.
(rumbling)
These stone steps
were not broken
by the ash and lava
from a volcano.
(rumbling)
They were shattered
by an earthquake.
ZORZOS: When the earthquake
happened,
everyone fled their town,
but then they came back to start
rebuilding their homes,
and this is exactly
what we're seeing here.
NARRATOR: Believing
the danger over,
people move furniture
into the streets,
so they can start repairing
their houses.
ZORZOS: We're seeing the beds
placed outside of their homes,
we're seeing the stones and mud
getting ready to be used
to rebuild these homes.
NARRATOR: But then they are
struck by an apocalypse.
(rumbling)
(explosion)
The first stage of the eruption
is so powerful
that it engulfs Akrotiri
and suffocates the whole island
in a thick layer of debris.
And the date of this
cataclysmic eruption?
Around 1625 BC, the same time
as the Minoans
begin to disappear from
the pages of history.
But how could a single eruption
trigger the collapse
of a great civilization based
on an island 70 miles away?
Until recently most scientists
have focused
only on the evidence
above ground.
But Evi Nomikou believes
that once again
the real clues lie underwater.
EVI NOMIKOU: Scientists
have been occupied
studying only
the on-land geology,
so we are starting
mapping the seafloor,
in order to find out
the total volume
of that big, destructive
eruption.
NARRATOR: Evi heads outside
the great crater
to hunt for new evidence
on the seabed.
And what she finds
is extraordinary.
Proof of the sheer scale
of this eruption.
As the waters of
the Mediterranean recede
still further, they reveal
wide stone terraces,
fanning out from
the mouth of the volcano...
the size of 20-story buildings.
They point to one cause.
They're called
pyroclastic flows:
torrents of superheated gas
and molten rock.
NOMIKOU: The pyroclastic flow
can cover everything.
They travel like a hurricane.
They can destroy
everything on their path
because of the high temperature,
up to 1,000 Celsius.
NARRATOR:
When they hit the sea,
the pyroclastic flows cool and
become solid ramparts of rock.
Around Santorini, they stretch
for a staggering 20 miles
in every direction.
Evidence of multiple eruptions
lasting for days.
By measuring
the stone terraces,
scientists calculate that
the volcano throws out
14 cubic miles of debris.
An eruption far more powerful
than they had ever imagined.
It's one of the biggest
volcanic explosions
in the history of the planet.
(explosion)
SYNOLAKIS: Let's try to imagine
what this eruption looked like.
If you were sitting somewhere in
any of the neighboring islands,
it would have appeared
like the end of the world.
NARRATOR: At first
the volcano blasts out
a column of superheated debris
more than 20 miles high.
SYNOLAKIS: This huge funnel
of black ash and cloud
could have been seen going
all the way to the sky.
NARRATOR: Some of the volcanic
plume falls to Earth
many miles from Santorini.
SYNOLAKIS: It would have been
raining pumice
on the surrounding islands.
NARRATOR: But now
the volcano unleashes
its most devastating surprise,
and in its path lies Crete,
the center of the Minoan world.
NARRATOR: 70 miles
from Santorini,
the Minoans on Crete see the
soaring column of ash and smoke
from the erupting volcano.
But they have no idea
of the disaster to come.
The volcano blasts millions
of tons of lava into the sea.
Triggering wave after wave
of powerful tsunamis.
SYNOLAKIS: When the tsunami
arrived in Crete,
they were probably taken
totally by surprise.
Imagine seeing
this wall of water,
in some places ten meters high,
advancing in.
It must have looked like
this was the end of the world.
Totally unexpected.
The wrath of the gods.
NARRATOR: Entire coastal
communities are swept away
by waves up to 30 feet tall.
Ports are destroyed
and ships smashed to pieces.
And the gods
aren't finished yet.
After the eruption
and the tsunamis,
another disaster is looming.
Clouds of volcanic ash
cast a deadly pall
over the whole Mediterranean,
dramatically cooling the Earth.
SCOTT: There were a series
of effects from the eruption
that together fatally weakened
the Minoan civilization.
A tsunami event, a divine event.
The destabilization
of their economy,
the failure of harvests
over several years.
That was the moment when Minoan
civilization started to die.
NARRATOR: Without their ports
and ships,
the Minoans lose their mastery
over the Mediterranean.
Invaders challenge their power.
And as the sun sets on the
collapsing Minoan civilization,
new powers arise.
500 miles from Crete,
just off the coast of Cyprus,
the draining waters
of the Mediterranean
reveal a remarkable discovery
almost 2,500 years old.
What can it tell us about
the lives, the power,
and the pleasures
of the Ancient Greeks?
In the centuries after
the fall of the Minoans,
the city-states of Greece
produce dazzling art
and architecture.
Forging ideas in mathematics,
democracy and theater
that still shape our world.
The Greeks take to the sea
in their wooden sailing ships
risking their lives
to explore, colonize,
and trade with each other.
Hundreds of boats shuttle
across the Mediterranean,
linking settlements in
Africa, Asia and Europe.
They are the lifeblood
of Greek civilization.
But these ships are a mystery.
Only a few remnants have
survived to offer a glimpse
into how they worked
and what they carried...
until now.
A shipwreck,
recently discovered
in the seas off Cyprus,
is helping to bring this
lost world back to life.
Archaeologist Stella Demesticha
and her team
are unlocking
the wreck's secrets.
Where did it come from?
What was it carrying?
And why did it sink?
STELLA DEMESTICHA: It's pretty
deep, so it takes a while
when you're diving before
you can see the sea bottom.
SCOTT: It looks all very
higgledy-piggledy,
it looks like, well, someone's
dropped a whole load of garbage
in the ocean.
NARRATOR: But this apparent
chaos is packed with clues
about the lost world
of the Ancient Greeks.
DEMESTICHA: This is really
fantastic for an archaeologist.
NARRATOR: Exploring such
a deep and complex site
is challenging.
DEMESTICHA: Diving at 45 meters
has several constraints,
and time is one of them.
The maximum we can stay per day
is 20 minutes.
NARRATOR: It's almost
impossible to work effectively
at such depths.
So the team explores the site
using a technique
called photogrammetry,
taking hundreds of pictures
of the wreck
from different angles.
DEMESTICHA: So instead of trying
to make decisions at 45 meters
where your brain
doesn't work properly,
taking the pictures allows us
to have the luxury
of diving through the screen
of our computer
as long as we wanted.
NARRATOR: Using the unique
photogrammetry data,
it's possible
for the first time
to drain the Mediterranean...
allowing sunshine to illuminate
a site that's been in darkness
for 2,500 years.
(music)
The debris lies
in the shape of a ship.
Much of the timber hull
has rotted away,
leaving only its ancient cargo.
Hundreds of earthenware jars,
known as amphorae,
piled neatly on top
of each other,
many of them still intact.
(music)
SCOTT: Amphorae look very odd.
They look very ungainly
and not very well designed
to be storage jars or certainly
container jars on a sea vessel.
But they are a design that's
evolved over centuries.
And actually if you stack them
all really neatly together,
they do all make sense,
and they were the way
that you transported things
around the ancient world.
NARRATOR: Amphorae like this
give the archaeologists
some vital clues.
Their distinctive shape varies,
depending on where and when
they were made.
This one dates from
the 4th century BC
and comes from
the Greek island of Chios,
500 miles from the wreck site.
So what was in it?
Although the amphorae
are all now empty,
they offer intriguing clues
about what they once contained.
DEMESTICHA: In this case we have
the opportunity to see evidence.
This dark coating
inside the amphora,
we have to imagine that it was
all over the inside walls,
and it was pitch, or resin,
so it was a kind of sealant
to make these walls waterproof.
So we are sure that these
are Chian wine containers.
NARRATOR: Wine from the island
of Chios is highly prized
throughout
the Ancient Mediterranean.
The wrecked ship is loaded
with the equivalent
of more than 10,000
modern-sized bottles.
A hugely valuable cargo
and a telling insight
into the Ancient Greek trade
in luxury goods.
SCOTT: The Greeks
loved their wine.
This little wreck off Cyprus
is the tip of the iceberg
of the wine trade.
It was an absolutely fundamental
part of their society
and of all their
cultural experiences,
whether that be religious
or whether it be
letting their hair down
and having a really good time.
DEMESTICHA: The greatest thing
about Ancient Greeks
is their love for life.
They like to talk, to think,
to discuss, to drink, to party.
SCOTT: There was a great profit
to be made
in making sure that the rich
around the Mediterranean world
had a good supply of
very good wine to drink.
NARRATOR: Trading in wine
and other luxury items
makes good money for
the Greek city-states.
But their ships carry
an even more precious cargo,
as they traverse
the Mediterranean and beyond,
from Egypt to Southern France,
they spread Greek
ideas and culture
that influence
Western civilization
to the present day.
But this cargo never
reaches its destination.
DEMESTICHA: One of the most
important questions that we ask
in shipwreck archaeology
is why this ship sunk.
NARRATOR: The biggest clue is
the shape of the debris.
The way that the jars
lie grouped together
rather than scattered about
proves that the vessel
didn't capsize.
So what did happen?
DEMESTICHA: The ships in
antiquity were open-decked.
The hold was not covered
with a deck,
so when the waves were
very high, or we have a storm,
then the water was coming in.
NARRATOR: The ship is most
likely overwhelmed by a wave.
Pulled down by the weight
of all the expensive wine
to a watery grave.
(music)
As the waters
of the Mediterranean
continue to drain away,
they uncover unique evidence
of a titanic clash
between two ancient
superpowers.
This is the site of a battle
that would change
the course of history.
WILLIAM M. MURRAY: When they saw
the Romans in front of them,
they had one of these
'Oh, no!' moments.
NARRATOR: What can these
bizarre objects on the seabed
tell us about the merciless
rise of the Romans?
NARRATOR: The third century BC.
Rome already controls
mainland Italy,
and has ambitions to expand
across the whole Mediterranean.
But its navy is weak.
JON HENDERSON: Rome was known
as being a terrestrial power,
not a maritime power, it was not
known for fighting sea battles,
but they were set on
a militaristic path
of maritime control.
NARRATOR: This brings them
into conflict
with another superpower
of the Mediterranean:
the Carthaginians.
SCOTT: The Carthaginians were
great traders, great seafarers,
controlling most of the west
and central Mediterranean,
and it was that fact
that brought them
into conflict with Rome.
NARRATOR: Carthage,
from its position
on the north coast of Africa,
commands the most powerful navy
in the region.
To challenge Carthage,
Rome must first learn
a new kind of naval warfare.
So begins a titanic struggle
that will last for
more than 100 years.
The winner will dominate
the Mediterranean
for the next seven centuries.
Its first truly decisive
encounter happens
somewhere off
the west coast of Sicily,
near the Egadi Islands.
Here, according to
ancient historian Polybius,
the mighty navies
of Rome and Carthage
go head-to-head
in an epic battle.
He describes the clash
of two huge fleets
involving 400 ships,
and at least 100,000 men...
turning the waters of
the Mediterranean blood-red.
But Polybius writes his history
at least half a century
after the battle
and for a Roman audience.
So how reliable is his account?
However huge this battle
may have been,
no one has ever been able
to find any trace of it.
MURRAY: Taking the description
from an ancient historian
and actually pointing
to the exact place
on the surface of the globe
where the battle took place
is extremely difficult.
NARRATOR: Bill Murray and
a team of marine archaeologists
are on the trail of
some extraordinary finds
reported by local fishermen.
But the area they need
to survey is huge,
many miles across.
So first, they sonar scan
the seabed.
Then they launch
a remotely operated vehicle
to investigate the finds.
(music)
PETER CAMPBELL: As you're
watching the live feed
of the video from the ROV, and
it's going across the seafloor,
the shapes suddenly
pop into view,
and it's incredibly distinctive.
So there's a great moment
of excitement
as these objects are first seen.
NARRATOR: They discover
a truly astonishing shape
300 feet down.
CAMPBELL: These are
the rarest artifacts
we have from antiquity.
NARRATOR: So what is it?
Using the data gathered
by the expedition,
it's possible to pull the plug
on the Mediterranean,
emptying the waters from
around the coast of Sicily.
The mysterious object on the
seabed comes clearly into view.
It's three feet wide
and made of metal.
Its jagged edges suggest
a deadly purpose.
SCOTT: So these are
bronze battering rams.
They would have been attached
to the front of a ship,
and this was the main method
of attacking and destroying
ships in antiquity.
NARRATOR: Rams are
the superweapons
of ancient naval warfare.
The large vertical fin is
like a splitting axe,
and the horizontal fins
are like blades,
to slice through
an enemy ship's timbers.
SCOTT: You didn't
have cannon fire,
there were no kind of guns
a la Pirates of the Caribbean
or anything like that.
The only way to take down
the enemy ship
was to smash a massive hole
in the middle of it
and let it sink to the bottom,
and the only way of doing that
was to ram it.
(crashing)
NARRATOR: A closer look reveals
that this ram is
battle-damaged,
its metal edges
broken and distorted
by a violent collision.
MURRAY: In one episode
we're told that the men
up in a forward tower
were literally catapulted
out of the tower
and into the sea
after a ram strike.
And we're told that it was
an effective ram strike,
because as the ancient author
wrote, 'Bronze hit bronze.'
NARRATOR: And this isn't
the only discovery.
Based on data from the survey,
draining away more
of the Mediterranean
reveals a remarkable pattern.
Ten more rams, scattered
across two square miles.
More than enough
to convince historians
that an important naval battle
took place here.
But is it the legendary
Battle of the Egadi Islands
described by Polybius?
An unlikely piece of evidence
may hold the answer.
A single amphora storage jar,
found near one of the rams.
By analyzing its shape
archaeologists can narrow down
when and where it was made.
It's like finding
a black box recorder.
The team believes the amphora
is Carthaginian
and dates
to the 3rd century BC,
the same period as the Battle
of the Egadi Islands.
The historian Polybius
describes how the Carthaginians
are carrying supplies for
their soldiers in Sicily.
Could this amphora
be part of that cargo?
POLYBIUS: The plan was to cross
to Mount Erice,
unobserved by the enemy,
and offload the stores.
Then take on soldiers
in the lightened ships
and engage the enemy.
NARRATOR: But the Carthaginians
never make it.
Compelling evidence
from the drained seabed
now indicates this is
where it all happened.
MURRAY: A number of rams line up
and give us a bearing
that makes some sense,
and that's fascinating,
that is exciting.
NARRATOR: The words
of an ancient historian
and the evidence
of modern technology
both point
to the same conclusion:
this is the site of the Battle
of the Egadi Islands.
MURRAY: It was an important
enough event for the Romans
that they remembered the date.
It was actually written down
in a calendar somewhere,
and we know that it occurred
on 10 March, 241 BC.
This is not your typical naval
battle where both sides prepare.
This was a battle
of opportunity.
NARRATOR: The Carthaginians,
still laden with supplies,
head for shore believing
the coast is clear.
But the Romans keep dozens
of their ships hidden
behind one of the islands.
It's a huge ambush.
MURRAY: The lookouts spied the
Carthaginian ships coming in,
and as the Carthaginians saw
the Romans in front of them,
they had one of these
'Oh, no!' moments.
CAMPBELL: So we're talking about
tens of thousands of men
on board these ships,
and they would have lined up
across from each other
in lines of battle,
headed toward each other
at a great rate,
and smashed into each other
head-to-head.
(crashing)
(men yelling)
NARRATOR: Polybius describes
what happened next.
POLYBIUS: Before long,
they were defeated.
50 of the Carthaginians' ships
were sunk,
and 70 captured
with their crews,
while the prisoners
numbered almost 10,000.
NARRATOR: Another discovery on
the seabed is a stark reminder
that this epic victory came
at a high price in human life.
This is the last resting place
of thousands of brave men.
And it has been judged
so important
that its exact location
must remain secret.
CAMPBELL: There's nothing else
really like this.
It's the first
ancient battle site
that's ever been discovered.
It's just an incredible
debris field.
SCOTT: The Battle of the Egadi
Islands was the turning point,
when a Roman fleet managed
to absolutely trounce
a Carthaginian fleet at sea.
CAMPBELL: This was
the defining battle
where Rome went from a regional
power to a superpower.
NARRATOR: The struggle between
Rome and Carthage
would last for another century.
But victory here
set Rome on a path
to shaping the destiny of
Europe for the next 700 years.
As the last of its water
runs away,
the Mediterranean reveals
a final secret.
What can draining
the Bay of Naples teach us
about the glory and the
decadence of the Roman Empire?
NARRATOR: 2,000 years ago
Rome has grown far beyond
its Italian homeland.
Its legions control a vast area
from North Africa
to Northern Europe,
from Spain to the Black Sea,
and the Roman navy dominates
the Mediterranean,
from its port next
to the city of Baiae
in the shadow
of mighty Vesuvius.
Baiae earns a reputation as
the Sin City of Ancient Rome.
It's famous for debauchery
and excess.
But what really went on
in this seaside party town?
And why does so much of it lie
abandoned beneath the waves?
Now, marine archaeologist
Jon Henderson is exploring
the secrets
of this sunken city.
Starting with
the huge harbor walls
that once surrounded
the city's port.
HENDERSON: These are built
by the Romans.
They were incredible engineers.
You can still see
the artificial construction
of this very clearly.
You can see the brickwork,
overlapping bricks.
Amazing!
NARRATOR: Beyond the port walls
lie magnificent villas
where Roman emperors
host lavish parties.
HENDERSON: Look at this.
This is a mosaic floor
of one of the bath houses.
Looks like it was
just done yesterday.
It's phenomenal!
Absolutely amazing!
This is called the nymphaeum.
It's actually
an elaborate dining room
for the Emperor Claudius.
You can imagine people
eating food
surrounded by
these water nymphs.
It was built to entertain the
emperor's most honored guests.
Well, one of the things
I'm interested in
is actually the scale
of the site.
Much of the focus has been on
the resort area of Baiae itself.
But on the margins of the site
there are constantly
new areas coming up.
(music)
That's it, slow it down.
There's a lot down there.
NARRATOR: So why did the Romans
lavish so much wealth
on building
a pleasure city here?
HENDERSON:
The Romans came to Baiae
because of the lovely maritime
climate and the thermal springs.
But Baiae was also
a very important port,
it's a natural port,
it's one of the best ports
on the western coast of Italy
at the time.
NARRATOR: Wealth brought
pleasure and excess
to this Las Vegas
of the Roman world.
HENDERSON: There were parties,
there was drinking,
it was a place
to get prostitutes,
and writers at the time referred
to it as 'a harbor of vice'
or 'a vortex of luxury.'
NARRATOR: The famous
Roman philosopher Seneca
is appalled by what he finds.
SENECA: Baiae is a place
to be avoided.
People wandering drunk
along the beach,
the riotous reveling
of sailing parties,
the lakes noisy with singing.
NARRATOR: But time is running
out for this party town.
Gradually many of its most
impressive public buildings
and private villas are
lost beneath the waves.
What happened?
Based on detailed
sonar scanning,
draining away the Mediterranean
begins to reveal the real story
of the rise and fall of Baiae.
It exposes just how much of
the city fell under the waves.
430 acres of streets, shops,
warehouses, and luxury villas.
Draining beyond the town
uncovers the reason--
an extraordinary landscape,
shaped by powerful
underground forces.
The whole town sits inside
the shallow crater
of a giant volcano.
HENDERSON:
You hear about Naples,
people talk about Vesuvius,
they don't seem to realize that
the whole western Bay of Naples
itself is a massive volcano.
We're actually standing
in a volcano now.
NARRATOR: The people of Baiae
may not understand
the unpredictable forces
stirring beneath them.
DOUGAL JERRAM: And we know
we're sat on a volcano.
But it's not
your normal volcano.
It's this much larger and much
more complex volcanic system.
NARRATOR: There's remarkable
evidence of its restless power
three miles away, across the
bay in the Temple of Serapis.
JERRAM: It's really when you
get into the Roman ruins
that you can see
what's going on.
You have to look closely,
though.
If you look up
at the column behind me,
you'll see in the middle part
it's got this strange
texture to it.
Lots and lots of holes in it.
There's even bits of shell
on this.
This is a stone-boring
marine mollusk.
That tells me that this stuff
has been under the sea.
Time enough for those mollusks
to get to grips
with the columns.
But look now,
these columns are in place,
and look where those
marker horizons are now.
That's like a tide
on the side of a bath
telling you where
the sea level was.
So we know that this has been
dropped under the sea,
and it's now risen above.
NARRATOR: Can draining
the waters of the bay
even further explain why
this ancient landscape
is constantly rising
and falling,
and finally show why the Romans
lost their Sin City?
NARRATOR: Baiae,
once a major Roman port,
lies half-submerged amid
a volcanic landscape.
(music)
Jon Henderson has been
exploring the area
beneath the waves,
and he finds a telltale sign
of the power at work here.
HENDERSON: So we've got
all these bubbles
are coming out of the ground,
all this hot air coming up
from the seabed.
You really get a sense here
of the power that's underneath,
waiting to burst out.
Hot water piling out
of the ground under the sea.
I've never seen
anything like this.
NARRATOR: These underwater
vents are superheated
by molten rock
from the volcano below,
evidence that the forces
stirring under Baiae
are highly active.
Locals call the area
Campi Flegri,
the Fields of Fire.
Now, for the first time,
draining the water
from the entire bay exposes
an extraordinary site.
24 separate volcanoes
nesting inside the crater.
It spans an incredible
38 square miles.
But geologists here
have been mapping
deep inside the Earth itself.
Now, draining not only
the Mediterranean,
but looking deep into
the layers of rock below it,
reveals a fantastical sight.
Giant cauldrons of
superheated molten rock,
known as a magma chambers,
that slowly empty and fill
over centuries.
Evidence that this
huge volcanic system
is still very much alive.
HENDERSON: Basically you've got
magma chambers
sitting under the sea, which
operate almost like bellows.
When they fill full of lava,
the ground goes up,
and then when they empty again
the ground goes down,
and this process is
going on constantly.
NARRATOR: It's as if the land
within the Campi Flegri crater
itself is breathing.
SCOTT: You feel like
you're standing
on some kind of giant's chest.
You feel minute compared
to the giant tectonic forces
that are creating
the world around you.
NARRATOR: The damage caused
by these breathing
chambers of magma
coincides with the decline
of the Roman Empire.
As part of the city slides
beneath the Mediterranean,
the population shrinks
and the parties end;
Sin City is no more.
Today, the scientists studying
the landscape here
believe that pressures
in the magma chambers
are increasing once again,
and that could have
catastrophic consequences
for the millions of people
living close by.
JERRAM: We know
it's an active system.
So one of the interesting
problems we have
with something the size
of Campi Flegri is,
is it going to erupt big or
is it going to erupt small?
NARRATOR:
Big could mean very big.
In AD 79,
nearby Vesuvius erupts.
It destroys
the city of Pompeii.
Thousands of people burn to
death or choke on volcanic ash.
But scientists know
the volcanic system
feeding the Fields of Fire
is far larger
and far more powerful
than Vesuvius.
And with so many people
living nearby,
it's vital to keep a close eye
on the breathing giant
beneath them.
JERRAM: It's even more critical
that we monitor
volcanoes like this,
and that's because we're verging
on the side of what we call
a supervolcano.
NARRATOR: Even the smallest
changes in the ground level,
or its temperature, could be
a vital warning sign
that the unstoppable forces of
nature are about to turn ugly.
JERRAM: If we had an eruption
where these multiple craters
evacuated,
it would be devastating.
It would essentially
flatten this area.
NARRATOR: The eruption could be
almost ten times more powerful
than the one at Santorini that
shattered the Minoan world.
(music)
Vast amounts
of volcanic material
would be ejected
into the atmosphere,
blocking out the sunlight.
Global temperatures
would plummet
with devastating consequences.
New scanning technology
reveals remarkable evidence
lying hidden beneath the waters
of the Mediterranean.
The raw forces of nature
still shaping
this volcanic landscape.
Priceless evidence of the trade
that drove the ancient world,
and an epic battle that changed
the course of history.